[Music]
a powerful earthquake hit yesterday in
mexico so far leaving at least one
person dead it hit near the pacific
resort city of acapulco now the quake
was last night but as expected there
have been powerful aftershocks all day
reporter sally jaramillo in studio
tonight with some reaction for us at 6.
denise the earthquake registered as a
7.0 located only 10 miles northeast of
acapulco now let's zoom in we do want to
show you a better image
where of course
these lights were appearing in the
atmosphere and many sharing these images
on social media today i spoke to paulina
cuevas who lives in las vegas she used
to live in acapulco and says her family
who is still there says it was awful
they are okay but soon after the quake
her friends started sending her images
and videos she described as chaotic she
says it reminded her of the earthquake
there in 2017.
i saw like every um the supermarket um
the hotels the like the plazas
everything is damaged like the all the
crystals
cuevas says her friends also telling her
they couldn't sleep due to all the
aftershocks there were more than 200
after the earthquake now her message
tonight to be strong and help our people
in mexico by donating to the mexican red
cross reporting in studio sally
jaramillo 8 news now